there is a chance that covid-19 was
created in a lab and then it leaked out
and infected the world the Chinese city
where the coronavirus pandemic is
believed to have started competent
trustworthy scientists probably it was
incompetent somebody was stupid whoa did
I just say that yes I did six months ago
I would not have been able to say that
but today I can and we need to talk
about it humans including myself hate
uncertainty ambiguity we want to know
what happened but in the case of
covid-19 we still don't know exactly
what happened we don't know where it
came from and to try to get at the real
answer you have to navigate all sorts of
politics but wait isn't this a science
question is this a matter of
epidemiology the origin of a virus it
should be but woven into this scientific
question are a bunch of heavy political
questions and considerations that are
influencing what kind of questions we're
allowed to ask and what kind of answers
were allowed to give so I want to strip
away the politics the tension with China
the idea that this all sounds like one
big conspiracy and I want to just look
at the evidence of one question which is
where did covid-19 come from the most
trafficked wild animal in the world
Wuhan also has China's only biosafety
level four super laboratory China has a
history of lab accidents are you
suggesting that maybe some evidence that
this was not a naturally occurring virus
so it's not just me who wants to know
the answer to this last month President
Biden asked the U.S intelligence
Community to double down in answering
this one question where did covid come
from it's important to know the answer
to that right now there are two major
hypotheses one is the spillover
hypothesis and the second one is the lab
leak hypothesis which has up until
recently been seen as a fringe
conspiracy theory complete baloney and
I'm going to explain why that changed in
just a minute but first let's look at
each of these first the spillover
hypothesis Health officials believe
covid-19 originated in animals sold in a
so-called wet Market in China
the spillover hypothesis says that the
coronavirus came from bats in China
which is pretty predictable bats in
China have tons of coronaviruses all the
time they're usually not infectious to
humans but the hypothesis says that a
strain came about that was infectious
just to maybe an animal maybe one of
these guys a Pangolin and then that
animal showed up in some supply chain
some Market in central China and it came
in contact with a human and the human
got coveted 19. and in fact for a while
it was this particular Market in Wuhan
that was seen as the culprit they
thought the bat virus was in an animal
somewhere in this market and now listen
for a really long time up until just
recently I didn't know this was a
hypothesis I thought this was a fact
like in the early days of the pandemic
they would talk about this like it
wasn't a question they'd be like and the
virus that came from this meat market
the virus originated from a market this
meat market ground zero for the outbreak
but guess what there's no direct
evidence for this they don't even have
pangolins in the Wuhan wet market and
soon we learned that the first official
covet case had no contact with this
market so the Chinese CDC had to come
out and say okay no it actually has
nothing to do with this Market we have
no idea where this outbreak came from
but even after they said that the market
wasn't the epicenter the idea was still
that this came from a bat that
transferred it to an animal that
transferred it to a human the spillover
hypothesis the main reason why this
hypothesis gained so much traction was
because this is how pandemics usually
happen of the past five pandemics four
of them were the result of a virus
jumping from an animal onto humans so
even though no one had found an animal
with covid-19 to prove this Theory they
sort of presumed that it had to be
because look at these other four but
wait what about this one the Russian flu
of 1977 was likely the result of a lab
accident and it ended up killing
hundreds of thousands of people but even
still the spillover hypothesis was kind
of gospel
hey real quick I'm going to be doing a q
a on Discord next week a week from today
on Thursday it's going to be a live
stage event which is sort of like a
personal like chat with whoever wants to
join Discord by the way is the sponsor
of today's video thank you Discord but
anyway this event is where you can join
and ask me whatever questions you want
and I will be talking for an hour about
storytelling and about my process and
about the future of documentary things
and bright trip and all of the things I
will be answering all of your questions
in this sort of personal back and forth
Discord live stage setting anyone can
join it's free all you have to do is
sign up for Discord which is like a 15
second process sign up for Discord
there's a link in my description where
you can register for this q a event
which is next week Thursday at noon
eastern time okay so I'm going to put on
the screen what time that is in other
time zones around the world
noon eastern time on Thursday I will be
answering tons of questions on Discord
as a live stage event
and I'm kind of excited to hear from all
of you to hear what questions you have
and to chat and catch up and see what
people are thinking about so thank you
Discord for sponsoring this video let's
get back to it but quietly there was
another theory that was brewing under
the surface one that many experts didn't
talk about publicly at the time but they
thought about they were thinking of
another building in Wuhan not this
Market but another building that was
just a few miles down the road this one
right here the Wuhan Institute of
virology so here's what's crazy it's
exactly in this specific lab in Wuhan
where scientists have been experimenting
for years with coronaviruses engineering
them to make them even more infectious
to human beings more infectious to
humans Whoa by the way that's paji he's
one of my producers he reached out to me
a while back and said that we should
look into the alternative hypotheses of
where covid came from including this
idea that it may have leaked from this
lab at the time I was quite skeptical I
had heard Rumblings about the idea of a
lab accident that caused covet and I'd
sort of written it off because it just
seemed so conspiracy like just like low
hanging fruit conspiracy like super
engineered virus escapes from lab and
starts Global pandemic it's like new
world orders it just reeks of like
internet conspiracy and disinformation
and in addition to that the only people
who were touting this were like people
who are not very good at the truth and
people who also liked to pick fights
with China I can tell you that there is
a significant amount of evidence that
this came from that laboratory in Wuhan
but I told paji that if there's any
evidence even circumstantial that
warrants looking further into this
hypothesis I would be interested in
checking it out
and it turns out there was such evidence
and here it goes
so this is the lab leak hypothesis and
I'm going to unpack it the best I can
first let's talk about this lab it's
located in central China the city of
Wuhan and for years they have been
experimenting on coronaviruses what Padu
was telling me about the question is why
on Earth would you want to make a
coronavirus more infectious to humans so
this is what's known as gain of
functional research and the idea is to
study more infectious versions of the
virus in order to learn from that what
we need in order to stop the next
pandemic from ever happening in the
first place gain of function research
this is sort of like testing nuclear
weapons you're sort of playing with fire
testing something that has the power to
kill millions of people but you're doing
so in the name of like helping Humanity
there are only three places on Earth
that do this sort of risky research and
it's supposed to be done in these super
high security biosecure facilities that
have all these parameters to make sure
that the engineered virus doesn't escape
and by the way in the scientific
Community many people think this is too
risky and not worth it one critique I
read from a scientific journal said that
quote if the virus escapes nobody could
predict the trajectory we're messing
with genetics and that's scary okay but
just remember for a second that all this
gain of function research is happening
in like 2015 through 2018.
for a second none of us had heard the
word coronavirus before this was
effectively some boring wonky nerdy
debate happening between super Niche
scientists who were studying the best
way to look at viruses and all the while
as they did this work studying all of
these coronaviruses from bats the
freezers in this lab in Wuhan started
filling up with more and more samples of
coronaviruses of all kinds some just
captured from bats and caves and others
engineered to be more infectious to
humans but again no one really cared if
I had made a video about this work in
2017 you wouldn't have watched it but in
2017 there was someone who did care it
was someone at the U.S embassy in
Beijing they caught wind that in this
Wuhan lab they were curating
coronaviruses and Engineering more
infectious ones this wasn't some secret
this was like in collaboration with
Scientists in the U.S and around the
world but even still they sent a team of
Health experts to check out the lab and
what they saw troubled them the lab
wasn't nearly as safe as it needed to be
and the managers at the lab said that
they were lobbying for more resources so
that they could hire properly trained
technicians to safely run the lab the
diplomats were concerned and they sent
two messages back to Washington DC at
two different periods of time they said
they this lab isn't safe and and the
state department should work with the
Chinese to tighten security these two
cables went back to Washington DC and
both were ignored again this was like
super boring stuff in 2017 and 2018. no
one had heard of Anthony fauci this
wasn't top priority so it was ignored
until 2020 when suddenly we all care
about virology concerns about the deadly
coronavirus officially hitting the U.S
okay so you have this lab that's doing
gain of function research they're maybe
not very secure now it's 20 20 and I
need to explain something that was hard
for me to understand at first but it's
very important any hypothesis as to the
origins of covid has to take into
account the fact that this new deadly
coronavirus called covid-19 broke out in
the very city where the largest
repository of coronavirus samples sit in
a freezer in this lab some of which have
been engineered to become more
infectious to humans oh and the lab has
been deemed not super safe if the
outbreak had happened in some other city
where there was no lab with a freezer
full of coronaviruses we would not be
having this conversation this would not
even be on the table but Wuhan is the
epicenter of coronavirus samples on
Earth because of this lab oh my God
there's been an outbreak of chocolaty
goodness near Hershey Pennsylvania what
do you think happened like oh I don't
know maybe a steam shovel mated with a
cocoa bean or it's the
Chocolate Factory okay wait hold on I
know some of you were thinking this I
was thinking this at first I thought
this was a logical fallacy originally I
had said well of course it's not a
coincidence that there's a coronavirus
lab in the same city that there was an
outbreak the lab was probably set up
because there's a lot of risk of
coronaviruses so they set up the lab to
study it so that they could prevent it
but then I read an interview with one of
the top researchers at the Wuhan lab one
of the biggest experts in bats and
coronaviruses and this changed my mind
foreign
but her nickname is the Batwoman
you're about to become compost because
she's made her career out of going into
caves getting coronavirus samples from
bats so that she can study them she's
like a top expert on this stuff and she
works in the Wuhan lab when she heard
that there was a coronavirus outbreak in
Wuhan she was in Shanghai at a
conference so she got on a train to rush
back to Wuhan so she's on this train and
later she said in an interview quote I
wondered if the local Health authorities
got it wrong by calling it The
coronavirus she's like something's off
here Wuhan is in central China and from
the batwoman's extensive study into this
she knows that it's actually Southern
China where all the bats are and where
coronavirus is most likely to jump from
animals to humans way down here in
southern China That's where covet 19's
cousin Soros broke out in the early
2000s that's the place where there is an
actual major risk of coronavirus jumping
from animals so the Batwoman is on this
train shaking her head she literally
said in the interview quote I had never
expected this kind of thing to happen in
Wuhan in central China this is a thing
that happens in southern China not
Central China and then the terrifying
thought hit her she said quote could
they have come from our lab her first
thought was the health officials got
this wrong it's either not coronavirus
or if it is it probably came from our
lab that's the more likely scenario not
that it jumped from animals like it does
in southern China so no the lab isn't
set up in Wuhan because Wuhan is the
epicenter of coronaviruses jumping from
animals instead wuhan's relationship to
coronaviruses isn't that it's common
that it breaks out in wet markets no
it's because of the lab the lab is the
world's largest sample of coronaviruses
on earth now let's be clear this isn't
hard proof that anything happened this
is circumstantial but it is absolutely a
firm foundation for a hypothesis that
potentially this could have come from a
lab that woman herself that was her
first thought and as I've been reading
accounts from other virologists and
epidemiologists around the world who
heard of a virus coming out of Wuhan
they thought about the lab they're like
oh [ __ ] there's a giant lab there with
tons of viruses I wonder if it came from
there now listen this lady who we're
calling Batwoman the bat expert went to
the lab as soon as she got to Wuhan she
was sort of freaking out she had been
losing sleep and she looked at all of
the data all of the samples and
determined that none of the samples
engineered or natural were the same as
covet 19. none of them were an exact
match and she cited breath of relief and
she felt like okay it wasn't our lab for
most scientists that was enough proof to
put the lab leak hypothesis to rest
they're like oh yeah Batwoman said that
the none of the samples were identical
to covet 19. but for many others
trusting this one woman to tell us the
truth or to have done a thorough
investigation is not good enough
evidence for us to rule this out the
world who has suffered greatly because
of covid-19 deserves a chance to truly
investigate not trust one Chinese
researcher the world has reached another
Grim milestone in the history of the
coronavirus pandemic this is globally
the death toll has now topped a
staggering three million people but for
some reason China is not really playing
ball with letting an inquiry or an
investigation happen when Australia got
up and called for a transparent
investigation into kovid's Origins
including looking into the lab League
hypothesis China immediately retaliated
with economic sanctions on Australian
products like wine and beef what a
little defensive like wouldn't China
want to have an independent
investigation into this hypothesis so
that if it's false it can be proven
false and we can put it to rest it seems
like that would be in their interest and
yet they're making it incredibly
difficult for anyone to do an
investigation instead we have to rely on
U.S spies and Intel to like pieces
together the Wall Street Journal
recently reported that there was Intel
that said that three researchers at the
Wuhan lab got sick with covet-like
symptoms and they had to be hospitalized
in November 2019 weeks before the first
official case of covid again this isn't
proof but it's definitely reason to ask
more questions China stopped making us
rely on Intel from spies put the
hypothesis to bed and let us investigate
but they won't which is like incredibly
suspicious Mike at the end of the day is
profoundly in China's interest to do
this as well because look it suffered
too okay so that's the lab leak
hypothesis unsafe lab that's the
coronavirus epicenter and it Engineers
viruses to be more infectious for humans
has a little mishap which turns into a
global pandemic it's a feasible
hypothesis that deserves investigation
now listen if your brain is anything
like my brain what both of our brains
are doing right now is scheming to find
some sort of certainty where like oh
look at all this evidence here they were
in the hospital and Wuhan is actually
the epicenter and we're like we're like
piecing it all together our brains love
to do this to lay out the circumstances
and fill in the blanks so that we can
believe in some sort of certain thing
our brains hate ambiguity but please
don't be tricked by your hate for
ambiguity we have to remember that
neither the spillover hypothesis nor the
lab leak hypothesis have solid direct
evidence that prove them one way or the
other the main evidence for the
spillover hypothesis right now is the
idea that historically this is how
viruses like to start they jump from
animals onto humans that's a really
solid basis for a hypothesis we should
absolutely continue to investigate that
but guess what it's been a year and a
half and we haven't found an animal who
carries covid after a year and a half so
as of now it is still in the category of
hypothesis but if you read the news in
2020 it seemed like the case was closed
like it was a settled thing like yeah
the coronavirus jumped from from an
animal the Pangolin Pangolin pangolins
probably one of these pangolins in a
market everyone move on meanwhile the
lab leak hypothesis also had solid basis
none of the evidence I've talked about
today is new it's all been around and
yet until recently the idea of a lab
accident being the origins of covid-19
was deemed as far off Fringe conspiracy
this question about the Wuhan lab we
know that it's been debunked that this
virus was man-made or modified a major
reason for that was because there was
the Trump Administration that was
constantly overstating the hypothesis
claiming they had way more evidence than
they actually did labeling it the China
virus the Chinese virus it's not racist
at all no not at all it comes from China
which helped fuel a spike in
discrimination and violence against
people of East Asian descent and then
Tom Cotton gets up and says this the
virus went into that food market before
it came out of that food market so we
don't know where it originated but we do
know that we have to get to the bottom
of that we also know that just a few
miles away from that food market is
China's only biosafety level for Super
laboratory that researches human
infectious diseases well this is awkward
um yeah it turns out what Tom Cotton
said actually is totally sensible I had
written this into the script thinking
that tonkotton said some crazy stuff
about something what five Jacks actually
does it absorbs oxygen and that's really
important to know but it turns out that
Tom Cotton back in like February of 2020
was stating a hypothesis that a bunch of
scientists now think is totally legit so
nothing's changed we haven't had we
don't have any new evidence and yet at
the time it was written off as a total
Fringe conspiracy here the New York
Times Senator Tom Cotton repeats Fringe
theory on coronavirus Origins it was
completely downplayed written off and
put aside as a fringe conspiracy this
was a failure of Journalism and
journalism's job of looking into
hypotheses and actually validating them
based on the available evidence as Tom
Cotton says there actually wasn't any
direct evidence and there still isn't
and yet today nothing has changed but
scientists look at the hypothesis and
see it as totally legit and worthy of
investigating and I almost just got
caught in a pitfall trying to do
journalism and about to regurgitate what
I read on the Washington Post in New
York Times that Tom Cotton said some
crazy stuff when he actually didn't that
is dangerous when reporters just repeat
what others are saying and jump on the
bandwagon because it's correct to do
that what's correct is to go report and
look into the evidence
which is something a lot of journalists
didn't do during this time and so
scientists even if they believed that we
should investigate it and the media
downplayed it wouldn't touch it
until recently at the coronavirus may
have leaked from a lab in Wuhan China
U.S President Joe Biden launched an
investigation in late May why would you
have a bad coronavirus outbreak in Wuhan
and not in southern China where these
horseshoe bats are located Trump left
office and things settled down with
China a little bit and lo and behold
we're now seeing legitimate
well-respected experts on this topic
come out publicly and declare that the
lab leak hypothesis isn't a conspiracy
and that both hypotheses need to be
taken seriously until we have sufficient
data it's called science by the way this
is called science just look into
legitimate hypotheses but what was
troubling to me is that even still there
are scientists who are digging in their
heels saying that the case is closed
there is zero evidence that this Forest
came out of 11 China like this guy for
example he's a leading expert in animal
diseases and disease ecology and he's
been the leader of calling the lab leak
hypothesis a fringe conspiracy Theory
like since the beginning when we knew
nothing but here's the thing this guy
has skin in the game his NGO gets loads
of funding to perform research at wait
for it the Wuhan lab members of the
scientific Community have said that
dashek has a conflict of interest due to
his close ties to the Wuhan Institute of
virology and its leading scientist XI
Jung Lee so of course he doesn't want
the Wuhan lab or gain of function
research to be smeared like this is his
home turf or his livelihood and his
life's work comes from and he's the guy
we're listening to like we're letting
this guy lead out on the inquiry about
where the origins of kovid come from
foreign
oh and it gets worse so the who World
Health Organization sent a group to
investigate the origins of covet a few
months ago and this guy helped lead the
team I mean he's like a world expert but
guess what the results of what he came
back with were not surprising a team of
international experts investigating the
origins of covid-19 have all but
dismissed a theory that the virus came
from a lab and talk to people ask
critical questions got critical answers
and they've come to their conclusion and
I have as well and what they say is
extremely unlikely but then eventually a
journalist calls him out given that this
report rules out a lab leak isn't your
credibility on that a little undermined
by the fact that you've been saying that
even before you came here
no yes you can't go into an
investigation with your mind already
made up dude especially when millions of
dollars of funding for your organization
is on the line that's not science that's
self-interest and tribalism listen I
don't doubt that danzak is an Earnest
believer in his theory I mean he's a
zoologist by trade he of course he
thinks it jumped from animals but this
shouldn't be the guy doing the
investigation oh and it's not just me
who thinks that this investigation was
BS the head of the who literally the
head the guy who commissioned this study
said that the investigation into the lab
League Theory quote wasn't extensive
enough it was too hasty so yeah they
didn't actually look into it these
scientists are not actually looking
earnestly for empirical evidence okay
that was a lot
um there's a lot to soak in here and I
want to give you a few big takeaways
that are like the thing we should take
away from this video number one is that
we don't know I know we all hate to hear
this but like we don't know the evidence
I've laid out here for both the lab leak
hypothesis as well as the spillover
hypothesis is all circumstantial meaning
it's like you have to connect a lot of
dots to make it work and science isn't
about connecting dots it's about proving
something with a solid evidence we don't
have solid proof of anything so please
please please don't give in to the
temptation to now believe that covid
came from a lab it may have come from a
lab but it may have jumped from animals
after being infected from bats we do not
know we should investigate both number
two it is mind-blowing to me that a
hypothesis can be labeled as Fringe and
conspiracy all because of politics and
then it can just immediately get
reversed depending on the political
climate the media is so hardcore
downplayed the hypothesis of the lab
League they did so because Trump was in
office and he was using an overstated
version of that to stoke hate and 10
tension and lies so I kind of get it but
we sort of threw the baby out with the
bath water number three it is very
disappointing to me that scientists
whose motives should be nothing but
seeking the truth keeping everything on
the table that has any promise they are
digging in their heels throwing a
legitimate hypothesis off the table and
lobbying to keep it out of the public
and showing that they are probably
influenced by the fact that they're
funding and life's work is associated
with the other hypothesis that they
don't like I get it when politicians do
that but leading experts who are all
looking to for truth and guidance like
come on guys we need to stay open to any
hypothesis that has a reasonable basis
to stand on and we need to do that so we
can find out how this thing started and
ensure that it never happens again a
final note more than a year ago top
scientist has published a letter in the
prestigious medical journal Lancet that
dismissed the lab leak there they called
it a conspiracy theory so ABC News
reached out to all 27 scientists who
sign find that letter about a dozen
responded several of them telling us
they're not so sure this thing came from
nature and one scientist telling us he's
flipped entirely and he believes that
now the lab leak theory is more likely
[Music]